any sports fans here
possible that's awesome that'll help but
even if you're not a sports fan you may
find Value in this talk
um so today we're going to transcribe
um motivational Sports co-ops and drive
insights from them to see which ones are
like for those motivation or
inspirational using the grams speech
Attack on Titan
so
um
so you might be wondering like why I
chose this topic and
um like what inspired this talk today so
we asked I was a former athlete I now
developed in Python including python but
it was really about to move your booty
have anybody seen this movie it's from
like the 1990s 90s and 90s yeah great
movie uh it changed my life and uh the
movie really I can just quickly plan
it's about this young boy who's in high
school throughout the playing football
for Notre Dame you know one of the most
story football programs we've had to do
college football uh he wasn't very
athletic you know he was like you know a
little bit early Suicide People about me
was like nuts they're like there's no
way you're gonna play football so he
ends up actually walking off the team
the team as a walk by and so there's a
lot of three motivational speeches that
movie
um but there's actually a bigger reason
for this talk that's more like personal
to me as well
so this I know it's this is the
screenshot from 1990s so you have to
excuse
but uh so I played University basketball
fresh produce senior year of high school
and our Nemesis was the team called the
Milwaukee Washington Group owners and
they literally beat us like every year
Escape
um not only did they decent State we
would also play them during the regular
season it would always beat us so twice
a year they would always beat us they
had a really really good team like
they're starting five including some
other bass players like ended up playing
a really high levels in college so they
were just like a really good team and
like my high school team it was kind of
like like we just did not think you
could beat them whatsoever look there is
no possibility obedient and we started
to believe that we could not win the
gifts this team
so this is my uh this is myself and my
high school coach from Colin Coach K Jim
curtsy great man uh so my senior year of
high school
I actually called up my parents called
me up and uh he came over to my parents
house
sat down with us and he said you know
we're gonna we're gonna try something
different this year
and I'm like okay
I mean because this is really our last
chance we want to state championship in
the state of Wisconsin for girls
basketball
uh so the first day of practice
uh you know we're like I'm with my TV
shooting uh and warming up and he's like
everybody know put the basketball the
way come to this classroom and so we
started watching a film and that was the
movie Rudy out once again
um you know about a uh kind of a
unathletic uh kind of on the shorter
side he wanted to play football from
Notre Dame uh and in this movie so he
ends up making the team with the walk-on
and in this movie there's a scene at the
end of the movie where Rudy finally gets
into the game and he attacked as a
quarterback
yeah everybody's like here I'm really
really old fan that's very Rudy Rudy the
whole stadium is going wild uh and his
teammates picked him up and they carry
him off the field and it's just a very
emotional scene uh very enlightened
scene so every day before practice but
whole year we would actually watch that
scene of the movie
uh and then something started to happen
uh something started to happen like in
our subconscious lives and uh
if I know what happens
that's okay you know you'll find out at
the end of our time together today
so uh once again my name is Tanya Sims
I'm a python developer Advocate D Graham
a deep Preamble you're an AI speech text
company so we transcribe
um you know real-time streaming audio
and pre-recorded audio but to be honest
we're more than a transcription company
we've got a ton of features just
released a lot of understanding features
a couple weeks ago like symptom analysis
topic depression some of which we'll
talk about today and then you'll see in
action
um I am a former professional athlete uh
Emperor hiring Sports I wouldn't work
with pharmaceutical sales for a couple
years I've hated it it had uh well it
did teach me a little bit but I got into
Tech after that after sales and now I am
a python buffer at the fitnessgram
if you want to connect on Twitter with
me hopefully Twitter is going to be
around for some time but
but it's not you know always connect me
on LinkedIn as well
so uh the part that we are going to go
through today and you will see some code
words maybe you'll you'll maybe see like
what is possible
with the gram and python so
um we're going to transcribe five
motivations Works often I'm sure you
probably recognize some of these names
up here uh so the first sports talk with
transcribe is uh
excuse me but I got you Daryl green
um former NFL
player Hall of Famer so his Hall of Fame
speech is considered to be one of the
best politics speeches ever and so I
wanted to find out why that was
everyone uh the next speech is Kobe
Bryant
you know obviously he's one of the best
basketball players ever uh play in the
NBA and very very good motivational
speaker
uh then we'll transcribe a sports speech
by Serene Williams and she's like the
girl right like grades of Alternatives
and uh just an amazing world to win
the next speech is by Al Pacino uh it's
from a movie called Any Given Sunday
once again from the 90s and uh he plays
like this uh it's a fictitious uh NFL
coach and he is talking to his players
at halftime
and he gives a motivational speech and
the last speech is by um
a guy named Jimmy Valvano he was a very
popular college coach for NC State just
a big personality like players just like
loved him which is a very lovable guy
and so the features that we use so we're
going to use deep grams pre-recorded
transcription years ago you upload a
file and you have some type of like uh
postage file online we also have
streaming or live transcription but
we're not going to use that for this
property these things
oh that transcribes these texts some of
the features we are going to use
summarization which gives a preview and
summarizes
of the transcript I think the benefit of
this it saves time you know sifting
through every transcript and uh student
quickly analyze the summary of a
transcript
then we'll move into doing some top
protection of each of the top of the
speeches
what this does is just abstracts the key
topics from the transcript uh from the
text
the benefit of that in a way or quickly
determine what the transcript is about
and kind of like patterns uh in the call
and like if you have like maybe you're
transcribing call centers and call them
something you can use copy detection to
cook it and find patterns in those calls
uh then we will get into some sentiment
analysis just release the Deep Ram you
know symptom and else identifies the
Simone in a transcript
neutral column benefit it helps
customers communicate better with their
customers
profanity filter
which I mean I should probably you know
can tell filters out from Fanny so look
at how deep RAM does that and then last
but not least we'll talk about the
search feature at eprium which just
searches for terms words and phrases
that are transcription
so let's take a look at so we have a
leaf here we also have a python s2k it's
in on GitHub uh and once again
pre-recorded transcription uploading a
file or posted online file you
transcribe the speech to text
so this code here python
so this line here it's just initializing
the dram SDK with your API key
then we are opening
opening the audio file
uh and next we're creating a dictionary
with audio as a buffer and uh something
fun online type
um the Pokemon type and in this case
of audio as well
and this line is pretty much where the
magic happens uh that is where the grams
us if you recorded a transcription
passing in the source and optional
features they're like punctuation let's
just add the punctuary
and then we are printing Json get a
response back with uh
the uh the different uh features that
you that you use
okay so let's start our
give us let's start transcribing our
Sports
speeches okay so the first one is
for any football and so okay I don't
feel good I've never heard them either
um so fairly recently
um but it's interesting because he
he was he's considered to be one of the
best defensive quarterbacks to ever play
in NFL and uh he paid for the Washington
and you know what's now in the
Washington Commanders
for many years and he was inducted into
the Hall of Fame in 2018
and uh I became a football fan in
America
from State leader in life go Packers
kind of hopped on that fan away in a
little bit in 2011 when they won their
Super Bowl with Aaron Rodgers but
so Daryl green his Hall of Fame speech
is considerably the best and as I was
saying earlier a paint's best but why
he's consider to the best
so the summary for hero green
but I'll show you the code for how you
do the song right it's very easy but
um so I've seen earlier to look at use
case I mean kind of all the science
boards for the summer I speak here it
would be like a call center or your
customers who need to navigate with a
large number of calls and analyze
important conversations
to carry it in some case
so after transcribing zero green speech
like here is
uh you know Deacon Jones said I would
cry You Bet Your Life I'm going to cry
that's my boy right there okay Deacon
Jones I can kind of give you some
context it's another Hall of finger who
played for the Washington commanders
thank you he's older than narrow green
so kind of what I took away from that so
you may take away something different
but uh you know he spoke maybe he spoke
to Deacon before he gave his Hall of
Fame speech and he knew he was going to
be very emotional maybe they had a
friendship
that some type of friendship where vegan
was some type of mentor
so uh to do to add the summarization
feature to get that type of summary it's
very simple all you do is just add the
summarize
uh key accept the value to true the
python dictionary and this also adds
punctuation by default
and then you'll get the Json response
response with the summary
uh okay so the topic detection that came
from the transcript you know top of the
question once again distracts the key
pelvis from the tax with the benefit of
quickly and about identifying and
analyzing patterns in the transcript
so some of the topics that came from
zero green speech include you know topic
one parenting family topic two infants
topic 3 leadership
how before God Bible holy Gods fashion
Christianity Shopify and law God God's
Christianity religion so you can kind of
see where this speech was going
um it seemed that Dale green it was very
religious you know there's a lot of
represents so like family God we live in
Bible
CMC really loves his family and his
parents and he cares a lot about music
and so I just created a word problem as
well
four
uh the topic for the topics and you can
see how it fits out the Google people
here God Christianity gods
and the topic detection must have been
very very easy you just add that detect
underscore topics parameter to a python
dictionary I'll set the diet through
earns all the feature and this also adds
punctuation might be thought transcript
once again this will give a Json
response with topics
okay next Kobe Bryant
does anyone have like an MBA like top
five
yeah yeah I just Kobe your top five
wedding band definitely yeah
these are my top five two
um phenomenal you know phenomenal player
um
just an amazing competitors
very rare and then you get slapped out
so a really great motivational speaker
so let's summarize Kobe Bryant's
speech
so this may not surprise you but I had a
purpose I wanted to be one of the best
basketball players to ever play in
anything else that was outside of that
lane I didn't have time for it there's
one of my English teachers that said
rest at the end not in the middle and
that's something I always look like
so takeaways you know if you follow Kobe
Bryant you know he's very very driven to
be like the best he's always practicing
always getting better
you know never quit never gave up
so some of the topics from the topic
detection that came from Kobe Bryant's
uh that speech of his include Sports uh
Aims Sports scouting
uh there's gambling gambling is uh he
didn't say gaming in the speech but it
could be that like uh maybe it's about
taking risks you know Sports you take
risks
so exercise
Fitness Athletics
Sports
uh more parenting children
sports games vacation parenting children
so you know you can see very focused on
the games uh playing sports and hearing
people's children
um
and then word cloud competency was fixed
out here
sports games experiencies uh you know
just very focused on basketball but he
was more than a basketball
as well a musical finding languages you
can have a reader but in this speech
this is you know what kind of came about
hey Serena Williams
okay yep keep that thought okay uh so
I'll never forget so Serena Williams you
know they go hey Grace of all time
because I'll never forget your first
time hearing about Selena Venus
um I was in Kentucky visiting visiting
my grandparents and my grandmother still
made a Sports Illustrated with these two
little girls on the cover Andrews and
Serena it was like the most amazing
thing I had ever seen and it really
inspired me in my own sports career as
well
so let's take a look at the summary for
Serena
Williams
reverse speech or I believe I believe in
yourself
I always wanted to be the best
when I go out there I really have to
shut down my mind I have to say to
myself you know what I'm just playing a
great player but today I have to be
better I hate to lose but I think losing
has brought me to here today you can
achieve anything that you set your mind
to takeaways so we hate it you know if
he hates to lose uh will to win that is
like unmatched and that's why she's
probably one of the greatest of all time
foreign
they're obviously very different but
maybe it's about like this year's
competition with battle
world and I think this is pretty like
even distributed nothing really jumped
out at me here but we'll get into doing
central analysis
so Al Pacino uh his speech from the
movie Any Given Sunday
uh and in this movie he's a NFL coach
for this team fictitious team called the
Miami shirts and uh who's once this free
football team they'll be kind of like
all these walk-up players or whatever uh
so he's at halftime they're losing
you're down by I don't know it's seven
he's given his team like a pep talk and
he's trying to like ignite them because
they've had like some differences
um and so
he's pretty much fighting motivates
players
so the summary for that speech is we're
in hell right now and we can stay here
you can blank kick out of us or we can
fight our way back into the light we can
climb out of hell one inch at the time
and this speech is actually called the
inch by inch page he's pretty much
talking about they had um they were in a
bad place they were losing the game
but being able to dig yourself out of
that situation inch by Edge
topics for Al Pacino speech
game Sports gambling gender or
um Alan again taking versus Sports
Cloud evenly distributed nothing really
pops out at me here but we'll see the
sentiment in a bit how that kind of
changes
and last but not least our last Sports
Beach was uh Jimmy delavano very popular
coach at NC State very big personalities
here it's like you loved him but I'll
never forget actually watching this talk
of the speech that he gave back in the
90s again uh
show
and uh the theme of that speech was like
never give up and it was so emotional
because at the same time he was like
fighting a very very serious Battle of
cancer and during that speech he
launched like the street albino Cancer
Research Foundation uh unfortunately at
least about with Andrew it was a huge
loss for the college basketball
community
don't forget the summary for his speech
you know I'm very emotional
cash it man that's being sort of brought
in the heat of albino as it comes with
the territory I don't know how much I
have left and I have some things that
everybody to say if you laugh you can
crying you do that seven days a week you
gotta have something special
might take away from this summary
very passionate and emotional speech
yeah it's you know he doesn't know how
much time
look
topics really quick and then we'll get
into the sentiment analysis but you know
speech poetry answer love relationships
Sports Athletics speech cancer that
believes
as Sports
cancer cancer so you can tell obviously
from this topic that cancer was on the
top
behind rightfully so
word cloud and see kind of what is more
most prevalent in that speech uh given
the topics
so secret analysis
um you know identifying emotional tone
behind a body of text
and this is something that we just
released from diagram
so positives in for analysis you know
your attitude towards people have
problems good neutral your attitude for
the particular topic is it's okay and
negative your attitude for a particular
topic is bad
so using our deep Grand python SDK once
again
very simple all we need to do is just
add the sentiment true parameter there
um and you'll get the Json response with
the sentiment I'm not going to show the
response but what I did is like for
example for each of the speeches I'll
show you in a minute
um so like let's say zero green speech
remember he is our NFL Hall of Famer his
speech was about religion God and things
like that so we're exit but this is
Python and pandas combine to
um you know once I shot that based on
the spot but as far as the daytime
response is an aggregation
um
so you can see here Daryl green speech
there was like 10 instances of negative
sentiment 47 instances of neutral and 21
instances of positive sentiment
can I use math problem to graph the
average percentage for each of the
species to the year 58.2 percent
um
was negative of about 27 that's being
powerful
holy Grant speech that he reviewed you
know why you be the best basketball
player ever
uh 61 instances
61 instances of negative speech
159 of neutral 54 positive and one very
positive
and his graph here you know 56 percent
uh neutral 25.5 negative point four
percent very positive and only 20.6 of
his speech was being positive sentiments
three Williams
negative 11x into the negative speed 18
of neutral
and 23 positive
and her graph 31 the first page was
neutral 24.5 negative and 44.4 percent
of her speech was being positive
uh sentiment for Al Pacino
is speech digging yourself by a hole in
an inch
um
10 instances of negative speech uh 28
instances of neutral speed 9 instances
of positive sentiment
and uh alkylograph 59 neutral
18 of these people negative and 22
positive last but not least Ruby got
mono that passionate emotional speech at
the SPs about never giving up because he
was a common cancer
um so here you have um 31 31 entrances
of negative speech 100 instances of
neutral speech 52 positive and one very
positive
and human job animals uh graph here 51.1
54.1 percent neutral
uh 17 of the speaking negative 0.5 of
the speech being very positive and 28.1
percent would be positive
so the winner I guess talking
considering was actually Serena Williams
she had the most positive sentiment at
44.4 in Her speech that I believe in
yourself uh
so some other deep grams features like
we have a profanity filter feature
um profanity by converting it to like
the nearest recognized non-profain word
or like removes it completely from the
transcript
so
um I had to transcript that you'll see
in a minute with profanity it's actually
this uh coach company his name is coach
buddy Stevens and um
he's a college coach for a junior
college in Mississippi
they were featured on this documentary
called last chance for um on Netflix
and
he was talking to a team at halftime and
Coach Brady Stevens uses a lot of her
family so I figured okay let me find
what an audio of him because I know how
it was going to happen
I had to break out some of the words
here anybody
um so yeah so you know you can see where
the profanity happens right
um so
this is actually how you add the
profanity filter
once again very simple
keyframe you just asking for fan you
feel the parameter set it equal to true
and then the Json responsible bit is the
transcript without the profanity in it
um so let's look at what it looks like
without the planning you know I need
much much different than what you
originally saw
okay almost there
um we have a search speaker and we even
learn about the future students
highlighting a few things we don't have
much time
um
and this feature actually allows you to
search for single term
multiple terms or like search for freeze
so you can still for example in Serena
Williams transcript I'm sure she says
the word test
um so we could search for the word
tennis and her transcripts and
um
when you do that is this path in a
certain parameter uh with the keyword or
with the with the side of the search
word or term or phrase and I just put
tennis and you'll get a Json response
with the words found in the search and
what that looks like is
something like this where you have the
query test that's what we're searching
for and the
snippet that you get back once it finds
the word that you're searching for so we
got band eight tenths so that's where
that bird appears
uh diarization anyway from a diarization
or it's just
here's some of the Arts just about
recognizing speaker changes in a
transcript if there are like multiple
speakers so it makes uh the transcript
more beautiful
so it kind of separates it out and you
see here if you're like speaker
zero said this speaker one said that and
so on
okay so so we're going back to the
beginning of our time together
um I was saying that we in high school
we had this Nemesis it's a lot of
Washington they would always beat us
every year twice a year during the
season at the safe tournament it was
pretty bad it never whenever it would be
to
um then our high school coach made us
watching movie Rudy like every day
um a lot of motivational speeches and
scenes in that movie and some kids are
shifting in our subconscious mind
research believe in ourselves
and guess what
we finally did our notices
uh for the Wisconsin girls basketball
championship many years ago we like
crushed them by like 20 points and uh
yeah so it was a pretty cool pretty cool
to make that shift
start leaving ourselves and so
um you know for the most part we're
watching for most of us I would say like
motivational speeches like help us to
inspire us like it all feels like not
just
School uh so yeah so uh deep frame we
have something called The Deep green on
the console it's like an online
playground uh maybe musicians you can
try screaming and pre-recorded
transcription browser
um you can choose your you know um your
uh coding with python node.js uh you can
also use your scope link as well with
support by 30 different School building
models and uh we give you 150 of free
credit views for transcription
uh I just want to thank everybody for
your time today thank you to remind me
to New York City
um and yeah I'll open up for a few
questions if you have any
[Applause]
and compression you have yeah I noticed
in Kobe Bryant's speech there were like
three or four topics with a singular
turn uh game but why is that yeah
um so like like it was like games half
of one game top two but just only games
there were no other terms oh I'm not
actually sure I mean it's not perfect I
mean we did just release our the common
detection like two skills were always
improving on but I think maybe it just
takes to talk to the community yeah
good question
um for the sense of analysis like are
you analyzing each statement by itself
or are you like adding context to that
statement based on like the statements
around it so there's like a negative
statement
um in the middle of this like you know
speech but like acceptances before it
and after it maybe provide some sort of
like I guess positive context would that
get bucketed
um in that positive category or would
just go to negative that's a really good
question so I I'm not sure on that um we
do have somebody who aren't researching
back here we're customers
okay the perfect first half that's a
really really good question cool yeah
yeah
if you're interested in like looking at
how students actually delivered not only
just the attacks they can't work on
detecting like speaker variability
that's interesting so after another
conference completely spend somebody was
mentioning that that's something that we
are like
um we are looking
to do in a near near future
of the clonality In Like Houses
for your topic detection are you using
like a preset list of words because it
looked at the same words popped up in
each speech yeah I don't I'm not sure of
like the underwork
detection but I know that we did there
were a few words kind of like he was
saying like how like the topic games
yeah yeah but it came up in multiple
speeches let's say like yeah War showed
up in one of those speeches it kind of
gives the idea that there are topics
that are listed for keys
yeah we do have homeless like yeah so my
like my real question is
like I work in a dental call center okay
this wouldn't be able to detect any
topics that have been useful to me would
you be able to add topics yes we are
doing it because we are I mean if
there's like a more like a costume case
we do work with the industries I think
to help get those added but um once
again I was talking about earlier
scenario of the woman who one of the
research engineers
on top detection Therapies so she helped
add all the we call them understanding
features like top protection similar
analysis summarization so who definitely
sure
yeah of course thanks for stopping by
everybody thank you